in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Dave
and Donna are with us hey guys how are
you great very cool
welcome welcome where are you from from
Pittsburgh North Carolina
what is that near not much it's about 45
minutes west of Raleigh oh okay very
cool well thanks for coming over to
Nashville to do your debt-free scream oh
yeah wouldn't miss this for anything
excited to be here how much have you
paid off a hundred and forty four
thousand one hundred and fifty eight
dollars I love it excellent how long did
that take you right at 35 months okay
making what kind of money just north of
200 excellent what do you guys do for a
living I'm a mechanical engineer a
design steam and chill water systems and
I'm a communication consultant for a
health insurance company awesome very
cool so what kind of debt was this
hundred and forty four thousand well
some of it was consolidation loans that
we took out from our 401k because we
were smart we borrowed from ourselves
and then the rest of it was our house oh
you paid off your house all right so you
knocked out the 401k loan and knocked
out the house that's it yeah all in 35
months mm-hmm way to go that's not what
we intended to do but that's what
happened well tell me the story what
happened well in January of 2013 we were
really headed for some trouble because
our spending was out of control we were
putting everything on a credit card for
the points and the rewards obviously and
we then went to the 401k loans and then
it a buddy of Dave's at work loaned him
a copy of the Total Money Makeover we
thought we're gonna try this budget
thing and we were terrible at it
absolutely terrible that first year
because we thought that we can pick and
choose what we wanted to follow out of
the program and it didn't work very well
we held onto our credit cards hmm and
actually it was our son who changed
everything he was four years old Dave
had gotten a replacement card as hard as
expired he got a replacement card in the
mail was about to cut the
old one up and our son said daddy daddy
don't cut that we won't have any money
and he was for system the very next week
I guess we never busted the budget since
convicted by the four year old that's
right yeah this is the message he's
getting and this is not good
wow that was like a lightning strike
right there we realized what we were
teaching our son about money Wow
takes your breath away and everything
and so then once we got that spending
under control
we went nuts so that the first year we
paid off about 20,000 the second year 44
and then we looked at each other one day
and said we can do this we can do this
and finish the house off yeah so you
know that second year we developed this
little chart to put in front of us on
the on the kitchen it's got a hundred
and twenty boxes on it every thousand
dollars we started knocking those off
and so we were looking at that and we
had we'd built up our emergency fund
that second year and then paid off
forty-four of these boxes and then I
decided you know we got 80 of them left
but I think we can do this in one year
and so we just went crazy that last year
and paid off eighty thousand dollars
last year Wow we got to where we wanted
to we wanted to cross off boxes more
than we wanted anything else yep
there's nothing like a visual like that
and laying a plan right in front of you
that makes you go for it and you see it
every day okay and you can see it it's
it's doable I mean that's the thing you
got a great income so you were able to
just hammer this thing once you decide
to get control and to have a very clear
goal well that's excellent so what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is you paid off a hundred
and forty four thousand and thirty five
months so you know I think one of the
biggest things we've we found was you
know we tried to do it all a cart
picking and choosing to that first year
and we didn't pay off that much but when
we really got serious about the budget
and utilizing the envelope system and
utilizing cash for things you know it's
like a mathematical miracle you feel
like you know you feel like you can do
anything once you once you combine those
two resources together
to be able to tackle that debt it's
amazing I mean as an engineer you have
to be a numbers guy I'm a numbers guy
and it's hard for me to grasp how true
it is
when I say to folks when you get on a
budget you'll feel like you got a raise
because there's so much waste in our
budgets and we don't have a plan
suddenly when you have a plan you have a
goal I mean you can squeeze this thing
and it's not like you're dying from it I
mean it wasn't like you were doing
anything completely weird you didn't you
know you didn't move into an igloo in
the back backyard or something I mean
you you know you just watched what the
flip you were doing and exactly and just
got control and so Kelly my associate
producer says you guys are Patrick the
voice of the Bulls that did the
wonderful debt-free scream that's now
legendary yours
you're his coordinator that was our
first financial peace class yes okay so
how many classes have you let we've led
six and we're getting ready to do our
seventh Wow thank you
and then I also did the financial
counselor training back in 2013 as well
you guys are like super coordinators I
mean why well thank you so much you've
changed a lot of lives then it's it's
it's very fulfilling to be able to see
people and like Patrick and and
Catherine and do the things that they
can do and how it affects their lives
and then it also many of them got boxes
on their refrigerator I don't know it
also kept us really motivated by you
know not only having a visual goal but
also going over the information
constantly nothing makes you learn
something like teaching it that's true
you know and leading the leading one of
these classes makes you do it I mean
you'll do the reading you'll do the
stuff you'll watch what you're doing
everything it changes this in the sense
of accountability is amazing so very
cool you guys very proud of you all
right Dave and Donna from Raleigh North
Carolina their sons gonna join what's
your son's name Matthew he is and
Matthew is 7 years old
all right and he's the star of the show
because he's the one that said we won't
have any money and it changed everything
that's right very cool right Dave and
Donna and Matthew a hundred and
forty-four thousand paid off that's
house and everything 35 months making
200 a year
down let's hear a debt-free scream that
he three to one
we're dead free
well done you guys man that's how it's
done right there Wow
awesome awesome awesome hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you are not a
victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim